[Music]
hello and welcome to marshall matters
with me winston marshall today i'm
joined by british comedy legend david
badill david has been a store of british
comedy since i was a little boy he's a
novelist stand-up comedian documentarian
television presenter and most
importantly of all
as far as i'm concerned the man behind
the most beautiful subtle and moving
song of the last 25 years
three lions football's coming home
his recent book jews don't count was
praised by sakir starma as brilliant and
he's just wrapped up his stand-up tour
trolls not the dolls which i was lucky
enough to see at the bloomsbury theatre
in london david thank you so much for
joining me thank you that's a very nice
intro i'm going to have to qualify just
one thing that you said in it which is i
mean i'm certainly not going to qualify
what you said about three lions uh but
uh i am not the man responsible i am the
man responsible with frank skinner andy
and brody for that song
of course very it was very much a
co-written song
but that's a lovely thing to say about
it that song
if you've done more with that song than
i could ever have dreamed to have done
in all anything i've done in music to
have a song that
is sung by the entire nation every two
years i mean it unifies the nation
completely
beloved by everyone
is that so an overwhelming thing for you
or is that something now that
is it still it's lovely i'm going to
qualify that as well because it unifies
england
it's much hated in scotland
and a bit in wales although i think
they're slightly more tolerant of it in
wales uh
but um
it is beautiful yeah i mean uh one of
the things about three lions i think
which is
uh important to me is
i think it's a really really unusual
example of an absolutely grassroots
phenomenon
uh in that when we first released it in
1996 uh having it was kind of weird in a
way because we were left field uh
writers of that song in the sense that
it was given at the height of brit pop
not not unreasonably to ian brody in the
lightning seeds and he said oh i think
david and frank skinner should write the
lyrics and then we because they're the
kind of nations football fans because we
were doing the tv show fantasy football
and then we cheekily said can we sing it
as well or whatever and the fa never
really liked it the fa always felt it
was a bit
like you know they didn't like some of
the references in it they were a bit
taken aback that it was a song
essentially about the pathos of england
losing all that kind of stuff um and
they didn't suppress it but they did say
we don't really want it played at
wembley
matches and blah blah blah
uh and so the song initially went to
number one
uh which was great we were so we're very
excited about that we thought that was
the end of it because then got knocked
off number one by the fuges and me and
frank just thought oh it's great to have
another one that's it and then we were
at england scotland in that tournament
uh and we uh do you i don't know you're
a titan you are a football fan
very much yeah
yeah okay so i went through those games
and i remember it being sung
throughout the games
but well no it wasn't it wasn't that
that's actually like a slightly rosy
memory of it it wasn't originally like
we weren't playing well like there's the
song requires it's a really weird
combination of sport and art because it
requires england to play reasonably well
uh for the song to be sung right and we
weren't playing well england drew with
switzerland in the first game of that
tournament and then we played scotland
and we weren't playing well against them
until the second half when gary
mcallister mr penalty and gaza scored an
incredible goal we beat them and the sun
almost came out at that moment and the
dj at wembley who i owe a great debt to
but don't know the name of against the
wishes of the fa put the song on and
here's what i mean by being a grassroots
phenomenon
we didn't know at that point but the
song had already been taken to the
hearts of people because the whole crowd
joined in spontaneously at that moment
87 000 people and we're looking around
thinking oh my god all these people they
all just know the words like it's like
the song has always been there right and
that was the first time it was ever sung
by a crowd at wembley but they all
joined in no karaoke
big screen at that point in time i
should say uh there's no forcing of it
it just happened and
it's an incredible thing i've said in
the past so i'll say again that you're
supposed to say the greatest moment in
your life is when your children are born
but [ __ ] that
this was
well above that
it was just an unbelievable thing and i
even though it's now much more
established and people sort of expect it
i still feel there is a spontaneity that
it chimes so much with what it feels
like to be a football fan and an england
football fan that people want to sing it
without any kind of forcing of it
well football is one of the uh recurring
themes in your
new latest book well it's not your
latest book i think you have another
book out there it's my latest adult book
i have a children's book out since jews
don't count if that's what you you refer
to uh i have a children's book which i
might as well block call the boy who got
accidentally famous i don't know how
many people who listen to your podcast
well sure a lot of them have children uh
but we'll be interested in that anyway
yes in jews don't count uh was my last
adult book yeah
and uh so football is one of the
recurring themes in uh uh
uh jews don't count now jews don't count
if i'm going to describe it and do uh if
you think i've got this wrong do do
correct me but i i read it it's a
polemical
uh from the point of view of a
progressive criticizing anti-semitism
within progressivism now you don't uh
you don't say that anti-semitism doesn't
come from the far right or the far left
or islamist as well that's a that's a
separate issue but you deal with
specifically in this in this book uh the
anti-semitism the blind spot of
antisemitism within the progressive
contemporary progressive movement so
i'll just i'll just qualify that a
little bit i think it's right what you
said uh i i um deal with uh
the adsense that appears in progressive
discourse in the conversation around
identity
and that so progressive is quite a wide
spectrum uh because i think that
although the people who are driving that
conversation are basically quite sort of
left-wing if you like their ideas drive
an agenda that is much greater than than
theirs so for example there's a moment
in the book a sort of footnote when
david cameron
calls me what i call the y word to my
face and i say you know this is an
example of what i'm talking about of the
falling out of uh concern around jews
because he wouldn't have done that i
don't i don't think he would have used a
similar hate word for another minority
if he was speaking to a member another
minority now you might say well he's not
progressive but i would say that part of
him that knows that you're not meant to
do that to other minorities is the is an
influence of a progressive agenda and a
good progressive agenda but that he
hasn't applied to jews so it's quite a
wide spectrum but also it's about the
differences between what you've just
described which is the very direct very
obvious very kind of straightforward
anti-semitism you get from the far right
and other sources as opposed to the
rather needing to be deconstructed
passive
neglect and lack of concern around
representation and inclusion and
diversity and offence that you get from
the progressives yeah that's what it's
about okay um and and uh so football so
the football that comes up
it's a bit of both of this so on on the
one hand you you describe incidents of
uh
obviously racist far-right racist
uh i would call it uh you you being
abused at chelsea football club um
and but then there's also this version
this other version of anti-semitism you
describe i think one example i remember
is you trying to make a film
about anti-semitism and and kick it out
being quite uh to be honest to be honest
that's a dynamic winston it's it's all
within one story uh and and in a way you
you you but you have uh a lighted on the
point which is
so very hasn't read it it begins with a
series of examples of what i'm talking
about the of jews don't countism and
in that particular example yes there was
a man at chelsea who inspired by
something that has gone on in football
for years which is the chanting of the
word yid what i deliberately called the
y word in a way to bring home the fact
that this is a word that somehow is more
sayable than other words that a man uh
behind me and my brother and we go to
chelsea all the time uh just start
shouting [ __ ] the years [ __ ] the years
and then [ __ ] the jews [ __ ] the jews and
in a way my point is so far right
racism towards jews exists
exists in football that's not a surprise
the point is in the programme when that
happened in 2008 it was already saying
any racist abuse any racist chanting
anyone guilty of that will be ejected
from the ground for life and there are
stewards whose job it is to spot that
and to apply that stricture and no one
did anything and similarly yes when we
went to kick racing out of football it
was quite difficult i mean they did do
it to be fair to them they did
eventually do it although only when i
paid for half the film and gary lineker
got involved but nonetheless they did
eventually put out this film the y word
about it there was an enormous pushback
initially to it
um so my point in relating that story
is to say look far right violent
really abusive anti-semitism completely
still exists but this book isn't really
about that it's about the fact that in a
culture that and football is very good
example of it that is honing itself
continually policing itself continually
about abuse and racism and all types of
discrimination uh coming from the
terrorists
how can that happen how can that happen
that that type of racism is so missed
out that i can be and my brother can
have someone shouting [ __ ] the jews like
10 yards behind us and no one does
anything yeah i i was thinking about
that uh not long ago there was these
west ham fans on a plane back from an
away game in belgium i saw it yeah and
there's a hasidic jewish man
uh taking his seat and they're chanting
at him uh anti-semitic uh
songs
and i do i do
think that the i believe that they have
been banned from west ham um uh and so
i'm not entirely sure uh on comparing
uh what their punishment's been to let's
say
the anti-black racism we saw over the
summer but one noticeable difference i i
found was that that video which was
appallingly
shocking didn't
capture the imagination
of of certainly not twitter but the
nation quite in the same way
that the anti-black racism uh rightly uh
caught the imagine you know uh was
condemned in in the summer is that an
example of of well that's a constant
thing i think i mean it's changing a
little bit um partly i think because
i'll be honest because of jews don't
count i think it's had it shifted the
dial a bit
so
if you want to use twitter which is a
complex thing to do some kind of
barometer
of notice of these kind of things then
issues around jewish offense get more
noticed they're more slightly more
likely to trend and to get some kind of
virality and therefore notice than they
used to but yeah um
that video got some notice but most
people listening to this still probably
don't know what we're talking about
whether whereas they will know what
you're talking about as regards uh
marcus rashford and the other uh penalty
takers who got abuse over the summer um
i mean there's all sorts of complexities
as well which is that for people who
don't know the the the chanting of
anti-semitic stuff at football has this
excuse actually just this morning um
there's a big article in the athletic
which is a sport thinking sport
publication
also online i did an interview there's a
big article in that a very good article
uh by a spurs fan essentially calling
for the end of the use of that word so
for people who don't know the excuse is
always given that that word just means
spurs fans right because spurs fans in
some way own the word and that's deeply
offensive to jews the idea that spurs
fans own that word because there is no
other example of a hate word for a
minority being reclaimed by a group that
is not that minority spurs fans are not
jews spurs fans are mainly non-jewish
they have a mythic slightly racist
identity as being very jewish they're
not 95 of them are not jewish and so
therefore they have no right to reclaim
that word but i know for for a fact that
those
it's very interesting that video from
that point of view in that those blokes
those west ham fans singing
at some level they will be thinking
what's the problem these songs are just
about spurs fans and yet they were
singing them
at an orthodox jew so the blurring of
spurs fan and jew is something that
happens all the time in those songs and
again these are things that just
wouldn't be allowed but i noticed again
twitter's a stupid space in many ways
but i noticed that when that article got
posted uh which is a big article about
you know it's time for spurs essentials
to stop singing this song because of the
various after effects it has and also
because it's just not viable anymore for
them to have whatever they think that
identity is loads of people still said
it's not offensive i i don't think that
word i've got jewish friends who don't
find it offensive blah blah blah blah so
a much stronger pushback than you will
get to the calling out of other types of
racism
i'm glad you bring up tottenham because
this is something i wanted to talk to
you about and and i totally accept that
it's blurry
what are you
i'm a manchester united fan uh but i did
go to uh tottenham
recently with uh
uh
tottenham fan who is uh maurice glassman
who's a man behind blue labor's
lord labour peer and
he has quite a different
opinion and i told him i was i was
interviewing you and that uh i
remembered from your book and i have it
here that
you actually just made this point if
there was a club from a part of london
that was thought of as predominantly
black and the mainly white fan base of
that club decided to call them
themselves the n-words or the n-word
army and that led to opposing fans
chanting racist hate songs based around
the end word back at them it would be
stopped and the club shut down
immediately which is the point you've
just made
now uh i'm not in any way want to excuse
the use of
of of the y word um and i've i've heard
it used in very offensive ways but he
morris had a slightly different slant on
on
the history of tottenham with uh i i
sort of know what morris's thing will be
but you can tell me but i know what's
coming okay well his is that the when uh
they were they were originally racistly
abused as the jewish club and tottenham
fans decided to own it and therefore
it's a kind of enveloping in their minds
of sort of support for their jewish fans
and that yeah and that's somewhat of a
british
kind of i in somewhat uh
there's a positive british humor to that
it's like
uh yeah and we these are our neighbors
these are our jewish
i don't you know look for start there
are
you know um a pocket of jewish spurs
fans who think it's great and part of
their identity and they see that
positivity
that they are small compared to the
wider jewish community that's one of the
things about this is that for a long
time it was seen as being like all about
spurs right but it's not all about spurs
and that's part of the anti-semitism
it's about jews right and uh
not just football fans but if we're
gonna talk about football fans jewish
chelsea fans jewish arsenal fans jewish
west ham fans who a have to hear this
being shouted and b have to hear their
clubs shouting it back with menaces
right and
there's one thing this article does
which is very good which
is that the the word itself not just the
associated anti-symmetrical use the word
itself is chanted by chelsea fans but
just in a horrible way right and that
dynamic spurs fans
are responsible for that in their
ownership of this world and the history
makes no difference because i think what
morris is missing out in is what a lot
of some spurs fans do including some
jewish birds fans if they make this an
issue of how it started and blame and
you know we were trying to do this so
it's only because chelsea fans and
arsenal fans blah blah blah you know do
they it's a and i just think no
that it doesn't really matter how it
started what matters is in the present
state that we're in which comes back to
what we're talking about which is the
context of jews don't count which is a
very very high
uh you know triggered and monitored and
policed conversation around what is
offensive the idea that you can have
twenty thousand people or forty thousand
people chanting a hate word for jews uh
and
leading to reaction from another twenty
or forty thousand people ever chanting
more extreme hate word for jews and
somehow this lovely history cleanses it
is bollocks
i i've certainly with you on on the
i don't feel like it's cleansed but i
remember going and hearing it and i you
do get tense hearing 20 000 fans
shouting the y word like that and
positive as it might be to some it is
quite shocking particularly in 2021 the
year
uh we've been talking about um uh racism
in football
yeah i think i think it's it's difficult
for
i'm sure i'm not i'm not i'm sure i
don't
absolutely don't deny maurice's
sincerity uh but i think it's very hard
for someone who's grown up with it who
has normalized it in that way a jewish
spurs fan to hear what it actually
sounds like on the other side of the
fence to a jew you're not to a chelsea
fan not to answer to a jew what it
sounds like
you know what i feel like what i felt
like by the way for 30 years in
chelsea when that chance starts is
frightened
that's what i feel not just cringy
frightened i feel actual sense of race
memory being triggered by
very very large crowds of burnley men
chanting the word yid hatefully and that
i'm afraid is utterly linked to spurs
doing it whatever you know nice spin on
it morris has in his head
uh well i feel slightly guilty now that
i brought morris into this no no it's
all right i can't tell all right as i
say morris is fine to make that point
but he's wrong
um with uh the jews don't count having
come out you mentioned earlier that the
dial's been pushed a bit and i i know
you you popped over to sakir's uh house
during lockdown he said at the uh yeah i
want to just make a point about that
yeah because a few people in all the big
there was a [ __ ] firestorm about that
um and i was trending for like three
days or whatever and did that thing that
i sometimes do now just staying off
twitter during that time which is
actually very healthy if somewhat
difficult um
i um by the way i've got a documentary
on bbc2 called
david badil anger social media and us
which is about the whole phenomenon of
rage and madness on social media but
also it's about my own addiction
uh to twitter and uh me trying to deal
with that and whatever uh but um
i didn't i should make it clear a few
people in who were being funny about it
rather than the people who were raging
about kierst kierstalmer said what are
you like an encyclopedia salesman now do
you go door-to-door with your copy of
jews don't count no i've been texting
and he'd be texting me kia stalma
kiyosad she doesn't look like he'll be
texting me you know i think part of
kierstama's project
in you know trying to exercise the
spectrum of anti-semitism from the
labour party is to talk to jews who've
got a voice and one of them is obviously
me and so he's been he's actually been
texting me for a while saying shall we
have coffee and whatever and then uh
that was before the pandemic and then
the pandemic happened then i wrote the
book which came out during the pandemic
and then in those conversations i said
well maybe you should just read this
book and i said i'll send it to you and
then when he told me his address it's
quite near where i live so i said i'll
just pop around and drop it around i
wasn't just hawking the book on the door
which is what it felt like a little bit
the way he described it uh but he was
really nice about it and
one of the interesting things about that
is you know there was
pushback you know uh the columnist owen
jones condemned uh kia stammer for
saying that in this way that i think is
you know very uh
certainly reductive of what my book is
about which implies that
sorry
what did jones condem
i'll explain uh i'll explain uh so
kierstarma one thing she says is it's a
brilliant book thank you kier it makes
it very clear
that
anti-jewish racism
is held as a a different standard he
says to other racisms right now that is
a simplified way of talking about what
my book is about but it is basically
right with the caveat that i am talking
mainly about within the space of
progressive discourse i'm not talking
about mainstream society where lots of
you know racism is much is as strong or
more stronger or whatever it's a it's a
much more complicated thing to talk
about in a way to sort of try and
you know quantify racism within society
in general but it would certainly be the
case that within the progressive space
you know and owen jones and others would
admit that there are problematic
blind spots having able to describe it
around what anti-semitism is and how bad
it is but he didn't but what owen quoted
was just kirsten saying that thing about
anti-semitism is held a different
standard to other racisms so he accused
him of um saying something that was
offensive to people of color by saying
that that that saying that is somehow
offensive of color because it implies
that the racism against people of color
is that they're privileged in some way
that they have a privileged access to
concern about their racism right
uh but what was weird about it was
obviously
the quote was about my book
so owen jones hasn't read my book i mean
you may have done now but he hadn't read
it when he did that quote but
the fact is i then got caught in a
massive i mean it wasn't just him but
i'm sure kirstalma endorsing my book
would have led to a firestorm anyway but
it certainly stoked the firestorm
and then he kind of slightly
disingenuously tweeted oh i wasn't
talking about david's book i was just
talking about kia stammer saying this
thing
but it should be understood
that
i am talking about a particular space
and also
i have seen people say who want to take
jews don't count down that the idea of
jews don't count is somehow offensive to
other minorities in implying that they
have a more privileged privileged space
or that their racism is taken more
seriously so the two things to say about
that is number one i think it is within
certain spaces within certain discourses
the progressive discourse and i'm just
going to carry on saying that
number two jews do feel this right one
of the things about the progressive ear
is it's supposed to listen without
challenging when a member of a minority
talks about the specifics of the racism
against them that's like an article of
faith is it not for progressive people
is you listen to black people when they
tell you they have suffered racism and
you don't challenge it it is definitely
the case that most jews in this country
feel that on the left certainly that
their racism against them somehow counts
for less than racism against other
minorities and saying that should be
something they listen to rather than
finding a way of saying you're not
allowed to say this because it's somehow
racist itself to say that it's basically
a tactic that leaves jews nowhere to go
if you then say you can't say this you
can't say jews don't count because it's
offensive to other minorities
so with these conversations
now happening within uh labour you happy
that
that that it's happening that that these
conversations do you think it's making
things clearer or i mean it's a very
these are a complex
form of of racism and uh is it
do you think
with zakir taking it taking you know
speaking about it that it's moving the
conversation along or do you see do you
see well yeah no i absolutely think that
but i think i talk in the book
which you might remember about how one
of the big big problems is that
anti-semitism in a weird way now because
at the end of the day calling out
anti-semitism concern about
anti-semitism should be just like any
other concern about racism right you
should just be able to say anti-semitism
is bad and we you shouldn't do it right
to be very banal but what has happened
is
because of the corbyn situation really
is that calling out anti-semitism being
against anti-semitism has now slightly
become something that the left sees the
preserve of the right
uh within the sort of team's
lane staying that people bloody think in
terms of politics now
so that when kierstalma says anything
about anti-semitism in my book i use the
example of the day that corbyn got
suspended you know kirstalmer said that
he wanted to build bridges with the
jewish community right now that's a good
thing and that and and you would have
thought on the left you think that's a
positive thing but no it's immediately
taken as this is a purge of the left
not even a moment of thinking well maybe
he actually means that maybe we should
think about this in terms of the racism
that he's trying to take apart it's just
immediately
deflected to being seen as attack on the
left and i think that happens now all
the time so that similarly him endorsing
my book
will be seen as like this is basically
kierstarma
saying something right wing that's
what's so weird about it is that you
know anti-semitism which is totally at
heart um something that comes from the
far right
caring about anti-semitism is now seen
as a right wing thing by the left in the
weird looking glass world that we've
ended up in that is completely bizarre
and uh upside down um
uh i i've noticed that uh one thing you
talk about
in jews don't count is is the
anti-semitism uh being a simultaneous uh
punching up and punching down where uh
there's the old trope that's that in
fact
both of these
apply to how the nazis treated the jews
where the jews run the world in this in
this sort of racist fantasy and they're
also
like vermin and below and that that
simultaneously happening at the same
time yeah that's right i mean the the i
mean so juice don't count really is a
series of examples of jews not counting
and then the rest of the book which is
the bulk of it i guess is exactly asking
why uh and there's lots of reasons why
uh but the sort of number one reason is
what you've just described which is the
jews kind of uniquely amongst minorities
at least in the west uh are associated
not just with what all other minorities
are associated with which is a kind of
negative idea uh so straightforwardly
negative idea which is their verb in
their low their thieves their liars
their dirt whatever
it's this high status negative high
status which is that they're powerful
privileged in control of the world or
whatever and although that comes from
the far right that definitely
exists as well on the left in fact i
would say that exists in society in
general i would say that notion of jews
as powerful and privileged and certainly
rich
and
that's what leads to the exclusion of
jews from what i call the sacred circle
of minorities at the end of the day
the notion of uh progressive support of
allyship is about vulnerability it's
about like oh you know trans people or
gay people or
black people or whatever are under
threat from power
and we need to support them
and the uh
idea that jews somehow are not indeed in
some cases use sort of our power
then then there's an ambiguity there and
that ambiguity is very clear to me one
of the things that
wasn't that clear to me
but became clear to me after i wrote the
book
is just how nursery level people's
misunderstanding of this is so i got
quite a lot of people saying to me oh i
didn't realize it was offensive to say
that jews are rich right
and
what i realized about that is not only
is it a misunderstanding in terms of
like data because jews are no more rich
really than i discovered when i was
doing some the small amount of research
that's in that book is not really a
researchy book it's that hindus
apparently they're the richest kind of
minority in the world because they have
the most millionaires whatever
but more importantly
i think that a lot of people
are thinking something very very banal
which is rich is good rich is good isn't
it so jews being rich that's a good
thing and what they're missing out there
is
the history because historically saying
that jews are rich is not good because
richness does not sit
in an easy way in history what happens
is people think
i don't think they should have that
riches and so i think i'm envious and
angry about that richness i'm going to
burn their house down and that's
happened historically over and over and
over again in fact uh
i was recently in york
and you may know there was a massacre in
york yorking i think 1162. don't quote
me on that 150 jews got massacred in
clifford's tower
most of them took their own lives
because there was a mob outside
and that started because
a jewish money lender and jews were
money lenders because they couldn't they
weren't allowed to work the land they
weren't allowed to own property in a
normal way uh they were one of the
things they were allowed to do was lend
but a jewish money lender
had
a lot of nobility had huge debts against
that money lender and felt he was too
rich so they stirred up anti-semitic
trouble in the villages and that led to
the massacre of under 50 jews and
this is just a constant thing in jewish
history is the notion that jews are rich
and powerful and privileged is never a
good thing it always leads to
huge envy and violence
um uh
judaism and uh these these
issues around anti-semitism come up in
your uh show trolls not the dolls which
as i said i uh got to uh
yeah thanks for coming i really enjoyed
it and um
i uh there's i i don't i hope this isn't
awkward if i recite what was my favorite
joke from the night but okay no do it
i want to do it i want to because i
think it sums up your paradoxical
relationship with
twitter
and um and the nature of uh
trolling and and uh and and i think it
sums up the show pretty nicely a show
that really
uh exposes the lunacy of twitter and and
uh but in a very funny way um and uh so
the key element of trolls is that they
have no empathy now empathy is what we
have to retain in our battle in here
with the trolls but i worry when i'm
dealing with trolls all the time that i
might myself be becoming a troll
and i have rules to try and stop myself
becoming that
number one
never have a go at anyone unless they've
had a go at you first but i break it all
the time
even if it's someone i greatly admire
for example here is richard dawkins the
great atheist writer announcing on
twitter the death of his beloved mother
i say
sorry to hear that richard she is of
course not in a better place
thank you for writing all that down god
you must be like a secretary from the
1950s in your ability to write stuff
down because that's word for word
correct uh well done yeah uh that's
frank's i that's one of frank skinner's
favorite jokes of mine which is
interesting because frank skin is not an
atheist uh he's very much a believer but
he likes the joke
uh that you know
for people who don't know the way i do
the show is it's a stand-up show but i
use a screen and i have some of my
tweets on the screen and some of the mad
reactions to my tweets on the screen and
that was yeah originally a joke on
twitter
after richard dawkins announced the
death of his mother it's interesting
because it's a joke that caused quite a
lot of trouble that one oh did it uh
yeah amongst all sorts of people
and i kind of thought
it's atheist solidarity isn't it that
joke because i'm an atheist as
you know another thing that sorry this
is now a sidebar but another thing
that's in jews don't count is that i
think that loads and loads of people in
history you used the word judaism
earlier uh i'm writing a book about
atheism i never see the way that i talk
about jewishness is really about judaism
i mean i i have a relationship to
judaism but because i'm an atheist what
i always talk about is jewishness which
is you know an ethnicity and a sort of
you know ethnocultural state of being
which is sort of unrelated really to the
religion or certainly to any idea of an
actual existing god
uh anyway they're completely unrelated
presumably i mean they're linked but
but related but separate well one of the
things i talk about in jews don't count
which is very important is that um
in terms of that particular conversation
rather than the more complex personal
conversation about how you could be an
atheist and yet as i do still do
passover and hanukkah and blah blah blah
and why i do those things
but in the anti-racist conversation what
i get a lot is people telling me um it's
not racist to be a uh you know whatever
to jews because they're not a race
they're a religion and they sort of they
sort of downgrade racism against jews to
the less important category of religious
intolerance and the thing i always point
out to them is that i am an atheist i'm
a militant atheist but that would have
got me no free passes out of auschwitz
and the important part about that is if
you're talking about anti-racism you
have to listen to what the racists are
saying because that's what you have to
guard against and fight against and
racists are not interested in whether i
keep kosher the bloke shouting [ __ ] the
jews at me at chelsea has no idea
whether i go to synagogue or not so for
me it's completely kind of irrelevant uh
as a religion the religion is important
might have some importance to me in the
way that i think more deeply but in
terms of the anti-racist conversation
it's irrelevant the joke you make is
that uh the the gestapo wouldn't give
two [ __ ] that your grandfather was was
an atheist yeah yeah and uh and also my
grandfather was not an atheist oh right
uh well
he he was a member of the koenigsberg
reformed jewish community and uh went to
dhaka after kristallnacht uh and uh
but i yeah me if they were here now uh
they would put me in auschwitz without
thinking about it and they wouldn't let
me go uh but um just to get back to the
richard dawkins thing yeah sorry
i think that was interesting because
it's a question of taste i guess
you know
i would like to know what rich i don't
know why richard dawkins didn't reply so
i don't know what richard dawkins
thought of that joke but i'm trying to
make a point i mean and you've suffered
at the hands of twitter right you've
suffered at that and you got trolled a
lot and i'm quite interested in you
talking a little bit in this about your
experience because i'm interested in all
that particulars i'm doing this
documentary about out of control anger
or whatever
but i
i say in my bit about richard dawkins
which is true i think is this is a very
new technology and we don't understand
exactly what the ethics of it are and
the you know the
morals of making jokes on it of having a
go at people whatever i'm trying to work
it out like anyone else and
if richard dawkins was actually upset by
that joke then then i'm sorry about that
you know but at the same time i'm
thinking
it is a joke about him being an atheist
and me being an atheist so i'm joining
hands with his atheism even if it sort
of you know might be a slightly you know
insensitive thing to say at that moment
about that his mum i get you know but as
i say it's i don't know where we are and
actually in the documentary i'm quite
keen on saying this is an exploration
it's not a you know definite this is
what this is doing to us program what
are you going to explore in this
documentary what is it specifically
about
uh trolls and twitter and or no no i
mean they're on it and it's not just
twitter uh uh it's
a sort of thought piece it's kind of a
television i was quite lucky to do it in
a way um it's a sort of thought piece
about what is it doing to us this level
of anger that seems to have been raised
by social media in general how much of
it is spilling out as i talk in the show
a little bit away from the screen it
doesn't just confirm the screen i
interviewed bloke whose house was burned
down a tick tocker whose house was burnt
down by in his opinion trolls i mean
they haven't caught the people but he's
become very big on tick-tock and getting
a lot of hate on tick-tock and then his
house is they set fire to his car and
then his house caught fire i interviewed
a lot of it is personal people so i try
and avoid to be honest in this program
uh talking about the stupid like actual
issues that cause anger
on social media so i don't talk about
anti-vaxxing i don't talk about trans
politics or whatever uh you might see
some images but i i don't want to get i
think once you get involved in the
issues then you get immediately bogged
down in like you know intricacies of
what causes huge rouse on that thing i
just want to talk about the level of
anger in general so that's what i'm
talking about i'm talking about and one
of the things i say on it is something
which i've said before but i feel very
strongly which is i think what twitter
is indeed what most social media is it's
not a marketplace of ideas generally
it's a marketplace of identity
it's people saying here i am and one
way in which people want to say here i
am is very loudly and the easiest way to
do that is angrily and so
what you get is a sort of like uh
monochroming if you like of identity
whereby people become utterly associated
with their political cause whatever it
might be
and then their best way of saying that
loudly is in opposition
the best way to say
i am an anti-vaxxer whatever it might be
is to be really really angry with
everyone who's pro vaccines or whatever
it might be you know
and
you see this all the time now these kind
of binary rows on twitter and i think
it's just people wanting to say more and
more loudly i am this thing
i am you know this political cause and
i'm gonna keep shouting above the people
because it's proving that about me
because i think at heart
human beings are very desperate for
identity it's about it's a sort of
you know philosophical and psychological
and a little bit investigative because i
also talk to professional
trolls a bit um and i talk about one guy
a guy called chris boozy who's amazing
who runs a company
that basically spots where private
companies have deliberately targeted
people
uh you know on twitter mainly in order
to smear them
and he says he describes that
practice practices apocalyptic
he says that's going on all the time all
the time now uh
private companies are being hired
because a has got a vendetta against b
or this company has got a vendetta
against that company or whatever and
they work with people who you would
never know were you know
it's not the ukrainian troll farms
anymore although they still exist it's
just people who are being paid to
you know
be horrible to other people for whatever
reason
yeah
um well this is
maybe this is what you were referring to
when i think you say in the show twitter
isn't real life until it is real life or
maybe this is an example of it becoming
real life but but also you're just
saying here uh uh the the monochroming
of of identity and and
you know uh respectfully you're quite
engaged in in quite a lot of these uh i
mean and you do it in a jokey way but
uh do you think that's
speaking for yourself a tool there in in
in
how you describe uh the twitter discord
no well i don't think so i mean i think
um
i mean
actually on the documentary i think
deliberately as a sort of
meta joke when we're talking about the
monochromatic identity uh we show quite
a lot of bios on various platforms uh
which are you know bios tend to be often
full of like the flags of identity right
and the last one is me with jew
but actually jew is a very complex
identity uh jew is not a monochromatic
identity it's like you know it's many
many things and it's a very deliberately
comically provocative thing that my
twitter biography is
um
and and as you know from the show it
provokes anti-semites which is one of
the reasons i do it uh i get people
furious that that's my twitter biography
uh i i think
i
um
i'm very interested in the idea that
identity is in fact nebulous
and uh complex and
you know much much more psychological
than it is political i mean even though
i think there are socio-political
reasons for obviously why we think the
way we do i also think that the
obsession with politicizing everything
means that the
complex nature and nuances of human
psychology get completely
forgotten about all the time there's a
brilliant woman called aisha can be you
should interview her she's a friend
actually
all right i guess yeah she mentioned
she's a friend of yours yeah yeah she
told me you gave me you gave her your
book
yes yeah i don't know if she likes the
book i'll be honest with you uh i gave
her the book she's interviewed in the
documentary um and i think she's one of
the most humane and complex thinking
thinkers on twitter
but i gave her the book and she wrote
one thing to me and then i didn't hear
from her and i think maybe she doesn't
like it and i wonder if she doesn't like
it because there's a there's some people
who think that the book is sort of
calling for the same
trigger offense identity blah blah for
jews as for other minorities and it
isn't it's it's saying that doesn't
exist and here are the reasons why and
here's the progressive attitude and
here's where it falls down with jews but
the book is not a manifesto i mean this
by the way i don't know if this is why i
used to think so i might be but i do
know i have some people who really like
the book have still said to me i'm a bit
worried this is sort of saying
oh i want
offensiveness towards jews to be exactly
the same as it is to other minorities so
therefore are you pro this kind of
trigger over
monitored sort of identity politics
world and my attitude is like i'm not
really in the business of like saying i
want or don't want anything i'm saying
i'm
analyzing and commentating and i'm
saying this does exist
for better or worse this this thing
exists this thing of people being
outraged and offended and policing
offense everywhere and it doesn't seem
to exist in the same way for jews why
not uh and that isn't really about so we
must do this because i'm not a sort of
ideological planner
i'm someone who commentates and observes
and says stuff
i certainly didn't take it as a
manifesto i i i think you say it a
couple of times ask her winston ask her
if she likes it i'm interested to know
because she hasn't this is just me being
vulnerable now because i really like
aisha and she hasn't written back to me
i
gave her the book about she said one
thing about it on direct message that
she liked the thing where i point out
the dawn butler's speech in 2019
mentions literally every possible
category of minority almost every
category of humanity and misses out you
still and she said she like that bit but
that's all that's all i have for my
issue
but as to people saying this is some
sort of manifesto i didn't read it as
that at all rather
what you if you're asking for one thing
you're asking for the conversation yeah
exactly uh
and and this this is very conversational
book uh and um uh anyway i highly
recommend it uh to um
anyone listening and uh actually pairs i
found very nicely with barry weiss's
book um on anti-semitism which is i
think a slightly different uh
look more from a liberal point of view
rather than a progressive point of view
i found and more and covered the far
right uh far left and islamism as well
as the progressive
yeah barry's interviewed me she's great
um
there's also another book which i need
to read uh called uh people love dead
jews have you heard of that no okay it's
by a woman called dara horn and it makes
a really good point i haven't read it
but i know what the point is which is
that
uh uh people in general but also on the
left or whatever
they will uh genuflect they will
you know feel respectful essentially to
holocaust mentions i mean other things
as well i think she talks about pogroms
or whatever but you know this notion
that uh
if you bring that up then
you probably will get some you know an
element of respect it's quite it would
be quite unusual except someone from the
really far right not to sort of like do
the whatever they need to do they're
sort of bowing of the head the silence
the respectfulness towards the mention
of the holocaust but the point is that
that creates a space
in which offense now to to living jews
is sort of made more okay i'm actually
going to america to talk about um jews
don't count it's just come out in
america it's a slightly different
edition it's got a preface it's got a
few more uh chapters in it
but amazingly i'm going on seth meyer's
late night chat show to talk about it
which is interesting i think because
you know i i haven't been on any chat
shows i mean i've been on loads of
things talk about it but the idea of
being on graham norton or jonathan ross
to talk about this book feels like
difficult so it's interesting that uh
seth meyers has
found a space for it but we'll see that
goes
it'd be very curious to hear what how
how it um resonates with americans
and uh what the similarities are going
going on over there by comparison with
over here
well it's very much is a thing over
there i think jews don't count on us but
it's there's a couple of
things that mix it up complicatedly
number one i think the notion that is
very strong in my but anti-semitism is
racism is something they have a slight
problem with because racism is so
associated i think in the american mind
with anti-black racism that it's almost
a protected word
um and so that's one issue
uh i think i think the other issue is
the lack of
there's been there's been obviously
anti-semitism in their politics
including in left-wing politics but
there's never there hasn't been
something like the corbyn moment
so
uh
oh yeah you know there's definitely been
stuff but the corbin moment what i mean
is
that for years
as a jew
i was much much more
um
aware of the idea that the american
jewish community were much more vocal uh
about their jewishness and much more
sort of empowered in a way than the
british jewish community the
anglo-jewish community who were to be
honest a bit british a bit reserved and
a bit like let's not mention that we're
jewish and let's keep quiet about it and
try and blend in even if they don't
allow us in their golf clubs whatever
right uh but suddenly
during the
2015-2019 they kind of mobilized and
there were there were demonstrations and
well it's hardly surprising because
anti-semitism was in the news you know
and it was a thing
so that was interesting because the
american jewish community haven't quite
mobilized as a political force in that
way even though there's many more of
them
yeah you mentioned that i think in the
book you talk about even in comedy how
the uh jewish uh
jewish nurse
characters like larry david for example
they absorb the identity
uh
much more so than british jewish
comedians
as a
curious yeah
no no that's interesting i mean
so another thing i talked about in the
book is
it's a weird identity in itself being
british and jewish uh because uh
there aren't that many role models i
guess is one thing like that thing i
just talked about which is the not
drawing attention to yourself and trying
to be a bit british about being british
and jewish rather than jewish
that means that you know they're so in
showbiz
where you know there are a fair amount
of jews and there are a fair amount of
jewish comedians i say this in the book
there's loads of jewish comedians but i
am one of the only ones that really
talks about it um so you you can name a
whole bunch of jewish people i'm the
only one who's made being jewish
sort of on the front foot of my identity
both seriously and
comically as well i talk about it all
the time in stand up and that's just to
think like the idea of not doing that
for an american comedian is impossible
you know what i mean the voice of
american comedy for many years was that
i mean it's changed now i think but you
know certainly sort of 50 from 1950 to
sort of 1990 the main mainstream voice
of jewish of american comedy would have
been a jewish voice i think someone once
said that friends is basically six old
jewish men talking around but but cast
with young attractive people some some
of whom are not jewish some of you are
david schwimmer or whatever but
um but in britain we never had that
and so it always felt like that was
something i was trying to slightly a
path i was trying to carve by myself a
little bit of like what does it mean to
have a british jewish comic voice
um david thank you so much is that it
are we done
well we've we've speaking for about an
hour now so okay um
i i i don't want to take up too much of
your time but i am genuinely thrilled
for me to to speak with you as i've told
you i'm a huge fan i really recommend
jews don't count to um
listeners and um
as i say goodbye what are you excited
about um what else can uh can we be
excited about for for you me well i'm
doing a juice don't count documentary
for channel four uh which i'm starting
to film with louis theroux's production
company so that should be i am excited
about that that should be interesting
david thank you so much for your time my
pleasure thank you
[Music]
you